we're doing here Sony been Sony been
Sony man how the hell are you
we're awesome introduce yourself to
everybody I'm John Garden on the
creative director
I'm Jeff Ross on the game director on
Days gone I don't it sounds insulting
but stick with me what a difference a
year makes last year you guys came out
you showed that first cinematic trailer
we're on the bike looks great all right
zombies were shooting zombies that's
cool and then this demo this year I was
like I'm all-in
because last year you guys had talked a
little bit about systems mechanics
open-world all that jazz I was so blown
away with this demo and you went behind
closed doors today yeah I got to see a
bit more of it and it's what blew my
mind was the demo that everybody saw on
the PlayStation showcase that was
awesome the demo we saw was the same
mission but it was snowing because the
the season was different like just the
weather was different and it totally
changed the gameplay of what we were
doing
so that scene that you saw where there
was the rope that kind of choked him out
and he like fell off his motorcycle in
this thing he totally avoided that and
went around killed the guys cut the rope
so we didn't have to deal with that and
the ambushes he dealt with in the
situations were totally different and I
was like this is so much more dynamic
than I expected it to be yeah that's
really what we wanted to emphasize this
year is just the open world dynamic
systems yeah so you know things like
like you said last year we showed the
Horde which is hundreds and hundreds of
freaker's and it was a life-and-death
sort of chase for deacon just running
for his life this year we wanted to show
how you could and I think is the term
Jeff came up with weaponizing the Horde
you can actually use right enemies
against each other because you know we
introduced you know Marauders so human
enemies this year and just the idea that
it's an open world system where
everything is alive everything has its
own needs everything has its own faction
and it can be used against each other
yeah so if we said a lot of mumbo-jumbo
last year like system some blah blah
blah really what we were trying to say
was it's a deadly world that's going to
try to kill you a lot of different ways
yeah that's a good thing yeah I mean
speaking of that like another thing I
noticed about the demos it is extremely
violent in a way that kind of makes you
feel uncomfortable
but that's the point like this is
obviously it apocalypse obviously things
are really bad but seeing some of the
the death animations there was a moment
in the demo I saw behind closed doors
where after he cut the rope he killed
one of the guys runs up on the other guy
like shanks him in the spleen he falls
back and he's like please no no and then
he just stomps on his face and his head
explodes I was like whoa okay but I mean
that's the world that they're in yeah it
is and one of the things that we really
wanted to do and you can see that kind
of happening right here is this is that
same ambush that in the media showcase
demo Deacon was distracted by runners
which are infected wolves and so he's
dealing with that and then he gets
clothesline and just BAM he's on the
ground and these guys are on him in any
alternate demo that you saw yeah he's
able to go around them and you know it's
like what he's like what he tells that
guy when he's begging for his life he
said no he stomps him he says you just
paid the price yeah you know you had
your chance and that's yeah that's the
world we really wanted to kind of
explore it was how you know it's like
how savage it can be how brutal it can
be you know but keeping it real so you
know we're trying to keep it as
realistic as we can another thing that
surprised me was how open the game was
like in the demo I saw he's riding his
motorcycle around and it was a really
vast open world and it seemed like there
was a lot going on where even if it
wasn't like side missions and things
like that there was like world building
going on like there was a tree with a
freak er attached to it by a chain and
one of the Marauders was giving him [ __ ]
and kind of like like oh you can't get
me can't get me and then you as a player
can shoot the chain the freaka goes and
kills the dude he's just like you
shouldn't been talking [ __ ] she got shot
you know in what we loved that moment
because as one listings were shows the
depravity of the world and how you know
there's we stomp the guy's face in but
there's no great people left in this
world I mean people who got this far did
some all this nasty stuff so in these
guys would have killed Deacon if he
didn't get the upper hand on them so but
the depravity in that we can witness we
also want to make that interactive which
is why you know the player had the tools
to turn that situation around and again
it's not a prescribed way of doing it
the player can choose to engage it or
not or try other techniques but we just
want to give the player a set of tools
where he can be as violent as he needs
to be in the context of this world
because it's it's a killer be killed to
the extreme yeah and like you're saying
it's open
so we really wanted to show off that
this is one small part of the Cascade
wilderness which is one of the regions
in the game and you know Copeland's camp
which is where the demo starts is one of
the encampments where you find you know
survivors who are sort of sort of lob I
think so not everybody is to pray
probably there are still some people who
have a shred of decency a shred of
humanity and you know that's kind of one
of the things the game is about is that
you see deacons character at the start
when Copeland is telling him hey
supplier we just got hit we got to go
get these guys and he's like that not my
problem ya know if that were the whole
story then this would be like why the
[ __ ] why the hell would you want to play
is this guy yeah right but instead we're
like no there's a shred of humanity in
there and he you know when it's his
friends and that's sort of where the
emcee comes into it it's Brotherhood and
loyalty and there are these sort of deep
traits within deacon and then that's
kind of what we want to explore over the
course of the game is like you know how
do you why do you want to survive in a
world like this what gives you hope I
was what makes you want to continue what
is I mean for what you can tell us the
narrative of this game because is it is
them MC still intact is that how he's
been surviving is what what are his
driving motivations cuz that's always
the thing when you get a bleak landscape
like this right where it is yeah
everybody's a horrible person why would
I want to hang out it's two years after
day zero right yeah as it starts yeah so
well you know so again we set it two
years after this event the pandemic that
were you know really not going into a
lot of detail about that yet but you
know that in terms of the timing and the
setting of it a lot of post-apocalyptic
experiences or you know 20 years on or
20,000 years on and we wanted it to be
just after so there's still a lot that's
sort of there's still a lot of resources
that can be found and gathered you know
the roads aren't complete the buildings
are completely destroyed you'll mostly
intact and you know that's that's kind
of why we chose that setting and you
know and then the same thing with the
high desert like you can see it's
snowing like crazy here and the reason
is because in the high desert it can be
July is the high desert is where Ben's
studio is pure coincidence
right what you know but it could be that
it can be snowing in July it's like it's
very extreme we get extreme weather we
have extreme all kinds of environments
within a very very small area so forests
and deserts and in a lot of - caves they
can be all be in a very small area yeah
I was also really impressed by so we're
going back to where Tom about with the
different skill trees
where there's the motorcycle and over
time you can build that up so you can
like drive farther and go faster and all
that but in addition to that there's
like that Detective Mode esque thing
where you kind of can see the tracks and
that as you play through that kind of
gets a little bit more advanced you can
mark the different enemies and like see
where they are in different ways and
what else is there like that well one of
the things you can see on the alternate
path is that we we show a lot more the
motorcycle going offroad burning fuel
taking damage so you've got to make
you've got one bike in this world and
it's his Deacons bike it's part of his
personality and you can't whistle for it
to come to you you've got to keep tabs
on it you've got to find it people want
it and you got that manage you got to
maintain it too and you got to upgrade
it so that's part of the motivation for
him working with these camps is that he
can they can help provide some of the
upgrades that he's going to need to
survive yeah we really wanted to you
know again it's the vision mode you're
talking about we call that survival
vision and then when you bring up this
wheel it's a survivor wheel so we wanted
to give Deakin a whole range of tools
and abilities that again are part of our
experience system and part of your
ability to like choose how you want to
play the game so you can do it stealth
and like in the in the alternate path
that you saw you can run and gun or just
any you know you can you can play the
way you want to play it yeah and so with
all the enemies it seems like so there's
the Marauders out there there's the
freaker's which are the zombie style
things but then there's also the
infected animals so we saw wolves in the
the demo but there's also that bear at
the end is there any other animals out
there so yeah you saw we call it the
rager so that's the infected bear you
saw the runners which are infected
wolves which by the way if you hadn't if
Deacon hadn't shot that wolf on the on
the media showcase demo it would have
knocked him off his bike so that's kind
of another example of how we have that
you know we'd say the world comes for
you and we in the last year we should
the Horde we showed swarmers we showed
newts which were adolescents when they
were infected and I think in the altar
in the alternate path demo you asked we
also showed crows hmm interesting
what I also like is how this demo that
we saw kind of took last years and like
instead of it being this massive swarm
of hundreds of them
we saw kind of just smaller mobs of them
and you can kind of control them and
shift them using noise by like
like in the demo I saw there was a dude
you put a bear trap down you threw a
rock to get him to go over to when he
got caught and he started screaming and
all his friends were like dude shut up
you gotta shut up they're gonna come
they're gonna come he didn't shut up cuz
he just got his leg bit by a freaking
bear trap and they could get shot in the
head by his friend and I was just like
that is insane but that's the thing is
the right play to pretend to get it
that's our world and it's such a cool
use to then seeing that the swarm kind
of come in and use a character just kind
of stealth hiding in the grass and just
letting them take over for you yeah
don't you know the Horde is the Horde is
real and it's like I said it's hundreds
of freaker's and early on in the game
don't met other way at least more than a
couple hundred you don't you don't mess
with them early on in the game you run
for your life that's what you do but
swarms are way more common so what you
see in the media showcase demo when
Deacon go through that cleft in the
rocks he's like hey this is a swarm that
you know that can be engaged really
really early on they're way more calm
and they're still almost as deadly as a
ward and then you saw also when he was
looking over the railing down at that
valley below you know again that just on
the one hand it shows how big our world
is because you can actually explore all
of that but it also shows you how
dangerous it is because these swarms are
everywhere yeah my question would be
this if you debut it last year you you
get it you get to see chuckleheads like
us talk about it now and stop what's the
biggest thing people have gotten wrong
about the game I feel like the more we
talk about it right the more we see of
it the more my impression of it changes
right where it goes from so many people
were like oh looks a lot like Last of Us
the more we talk about him like this
seems a lot more like horizon and idea
what for you is the biggest
misconception that everything's fake you
know that you know last year we did the
Horde thing and it was live I mean it
was it was the real deal and you just
can't win with this crowd or when you
play it one way people think it's linear
and that's the only way but and that's
why this year we wanted to show the
alternate path where it's like no this
is the same victory conditions but we
let the player go at him any way he
wants and it's that's the thing I bought
a message more than anything else is
that it's play it your way
figure out a way that you like to play
and just do it and the game will respond
well I do for me I think it's a you know
we're number one we're flattered because
you know all these games that were being
Pera - were huge fans of those games you
know we were in development alongside
you know most of them and you know and
we're gamers so what we want to do is
craft an experience that you know at
least for me I want to craft an
experience I haven't played before you
know so I think the you know probably
the biggest misconception is that you
know if we're trying to create are we
trying to create an experience that's
real are we trying to ape something or
mimic something and that you know that's
just not the case we're trying to create
days gone which for us is a brutal
open-world dynamic system and to me it
feels very different than most of the
games that I played up-to-date I think
the other you know interesting thing
coming away from this right is talking
about my misconception of it you guys
doing it but then you had a really
interesting story from behind closed
doors where they were asking you you
know like how does all this work like it
what's the biggest change from last year
and what I like from what I heard from
Tim was the answer was like well
nothing's changed there hasn't been a
drastic we're just building on the
systems we have is that been for you the
story of the development of days gone
having this idea and then just because
like we you know we always make fun of
Eric right of how long it's taken for
you guys to put out another game and
where is it's only been where I've been
and it's one of those like when you look
at this and you see and start talking
about we talked about the mechanics you
see it in on the screen it seems like
you've been working on one thing for a
long time but you want it to be really
[ __ ] good I you know I think one of
the things that hopefully is
this year and last year is our one of
our original goals was to make a triple
a console quality in terms of the
characters and the cinematics in the
environments because the ps4 ps4 the ps4
Pro let us do that yeah and you know
it's like so the production values are
really really high probably much higher
than they need to be for an open-world
game and we really want it to deliver on
that not and not just the way it looks
but also the way it plays the amount of
detail in the AI and the amount of
detail in the missions and the job so
yeah and it's a big game right so it's
like any other hopeful world game its
massive there's a lot to do and there's
a lot of story to be told which we're
not really talking about yet but but
yeah it's just it's just gonna take a
while to get there yeah very exciting
stuff
last year I was interested but now I'm
totally sold I think that mixing that
crazy mob stuff with the more open stuff
where there's a bunch of different ways
you can go about things there's gonna be
really fun game awesome thank you so now
when's it coming out we're not talking
about that good try dude nice try nice
try call him well thank you guys for
coming by uh Tim yeah you had fun
watching you today I did I had fun
watching it this is one of my approved
games somebody given there we go two for
two two for two cracking up with a
Frenchie lay box
pass it over there we go you guys are
congratulations guys thank you man
thanks guys everybody should come by the
Sony booth and see the alternate
playthrough in person if they want to
it's right about early that's pretty
awesome well thank you take care guys I
think you were leaves the stage ladies
and gentlemen give it up for days gone
Sony babe Eric Jensen made it all by
himself
Woo's guys were up here taking credit
for no reason